since we met with you last year you had
a chance to work with Jim Carrey did you
ever think this would happen
no the one of the producers at Funny or
Die had directed a film that I was in
and I got a call asking if I would come
and do it in the morning and I did and
there's Jim Carrey walking around
sticking out his hand like he's an
unknown actor saying hi I'm Jim and
inwardly you're thinking I know but it
was really very very nice and this is
something that I find with higher-level
actors most of them are very kind and
they will present themself that way you
know Tom Cruise or hi I'm Tom giving you
the opportunity to say hi I'm Karen so
that you meet on an equal level I think
it's wonderful so when you got the call
about this short film that you were
doing this comedy thing with the hee haw
were you aware that Jim Carrey was part
of it or you didn't know until you got
on set I was but I did it as a favor for
the producer who called me because it's
not my usual cup of tea you know I'm not
a comedian I don't do comedy and and and
it's not what it's something that I
usually do or something I would have
done had not you know a favor been
called in and I'm glad I did it was a
great experience it was it was an
anomaly for me but that's this sound if
you owe someone a favor and they store
up that favor yeah because they had used
me for some shoots before and I did oh
the favor and if someone calls in that
favor and says hey Karen's bill you know
I'm gonna have to do whatever this is
unless it's you know killing a child or
something because the worst thing in
this business is to be known as yeah I
did her a favor and I asked her for one
she wouldn't do it
word gets around so yeah repay your
favors since you shot the film and it's
aired on Funny or Die and I think it's
it's all over other YouTube and things
like that my veto is an impact yes my
mom called and said I saw you on Fox
News what's going on
so it
I don't usually get involved in anything
that makes any sort of political
statement
so my hometown newspaper of course you
know they want to do an interview so you
know I said it was an acting job and it
was fun to do and I'm glad to have had
everybody does it you know necessarily
represent any of my own personal
political views I think it said
something like three four million hits
something like that
take this lollipop has had over 110
million hits so far and Counting
so more people have seen me stalking
them on Facebook than have seen me being
the host of hee-haw how did that feel to
have sort of the local boy makes good
aspect it was very weird very weird
because you know how it is when people
in your hometown they'll be like I knew
Karen I knew her and she was growing up
who does she think she is you're always
very aware of that so you always want to
downplay everything so hey local people
calling you just want an Oscar oh yeah
you know I mean it's I needed a doorstop
and so I'll just you know put it there
so it's not a big deal you never want to
be the one that says oh yes I knew I
would do it I hate that I hate it always
knew this was gonna happen yeah
you